( >д<)､;’.･ ﾊｸｼｮﾝ
( >д<)､;’.･ ﾊｼﾞﾒﾝ
4回､ です､ ね…
科学の世界へようこそ！
ドクタァ━━━━━━ ハジメだ！
私は今、川に来ている
川｡
こんな広い所ですることと言えばただひとつ…
危険な実験だ｡
というわけで今回用意したのはこちら！
これ、だい…大丈夫なのかな、俺すごい不安なんだよね
こちらの箱だ
私は正直、ビビっている｡
正直 今ですら これやっていいのか ちょっとわかんないっす…
え、大丈夫だよね？
大丈夫…
ひとまず なんか、誰かをケガさせるような場所ではないので、そこは大丈夫だと思います
今回ネットで購入した商品がこちら､
Hydrogen Rocket！
俺、ビックリ…
これ 私は見たとき､
水素ロケットたる物が普通にネットで売ってるのかというこの真実！
ガチだからね これ～
大丈夫なのかな…
わりとホントに怖いんですけど、本当の水素ロケットみたいです
この「Hydrogen」っていうのは「水素」の意味です
で､「ロケット」
まぁ見た感じなんか…
見るからにやばそうなんですけど…
でも なんかガキ共が楽しそうにやってるんで､
たぶん大丈夫でしょう｡
実際にこれを使って、ちょっと水素ロケットたる物を飛ばしてみようと思う
市販の水素ロケットって一体どんなんだろうっていうね
たぶんペットボトルロケットと比べても全然威力が違うと思うので､
やっていこう！
(つд⊂)ｴｰﾝ こわいよ～
えっ待って、本当にするの～？
いや～ 水素なめたらいかんでゲソ｡
もう すぐ作っていきますよー！
あーこれがたぶんロケットです
これがロケット！
ぜんぶ英語になっております…
うわ、これ待って、マジじゃんこれ～
もう見るからに水素発生しそうな怪しい装置
これは何？ これは？
これがたぶんラウンチだな
ここにたぶんロケット入れて発射させる感じかなぁ
うわ、こーわっ
これ大丈夫かな、ちょっとマジモンなんだけど
うわぁ～ うわ、なんかもうやばい
なんかもう、なんか色々とやばそうです
うわ～ これ､
絶対これだ… 絶対これだ…
なんだろ､「水酸…」 うわ待って、漏れてね？
漏れてるんだけど
超怪しい白い粉が入ってありました
「Citric Acid」は「クエン酸」のことですね
はい、というわけで早速！ 水素ロケットの準備していきましょう！
FIRST STEP: Unscrew the two Battery Compartment
NUMBER TWO: Tilting the Fuel Generator to the side
Slowly add plain tap water to fill the generator half full
THREE:
[ ③ ボトルから燃料発生装置へ溶液を慎重に移します。その際、溶液が点火装置 (細いワイヤー製のコイル) に触れないようにしてください。]
こんなもんっしょ
Fuel Generation Solution (燃料発生溶液) をこの中に作って､
[ ③ ボトルから燃料発生装置へ溶液を慎重に移します。その際、溶液が点火装置 (細いワイヤー製のコイル) に触れないようにしてください。]
それをこのボトルに…
Generator (発生装置) か、ごめんなさい
[ ③ ボトルから燃料発生装置へ溶液を慎重に移します。その際、溶液が点火装置 (細いワイヤー製のコイル) に触れないようにしてください。]
Fuel Generator (燃料発生装置) の中に､
先にGeneration Solution (発生溶液) を作って､
[ ③ ボトルから燃料発生装置へ溶液を慎重に移します。その際、溶液が点火装置 (細いワイヤー製のコイル) に触れないようにしてください。]
それをFuel Generator (燃料発生装置) に入れるってことらしいです
ソリューション (燃料の元) 作ります
まず、水を240ml入れます
えーっとこの中に、さっきのこの粉ですね
クエン酸を入れます
よーし、どうすかね
Stir、あー混ぜろと
Stirだから混ぜます
OKです、完成しました
Avoid pouring it on the Igniter...
( 点火装置に直接注がないでください )
えっと、これがイグニッター (点火するところ) です
イグニッターの上まで水がいっちゃうとダメみたいなので､
イグニッターより下まで、さっき作ったソリューションを入れます
センターリング来たかな？
もうちょい
はい、センターリング付近まで入りました
これで燃料の完成みたいです
フュエル ジェネレーター (燃料発生装置)
で、これを次はこれをここにセットするみたいです
Insert the Fuel Generator into the launch...
( 燃料発生装置を発射台にセットします )
セット、これでOK
これで固定されました
で、次に ラウンチ チューブ (発射補助器具) を上にのせます
うわーなんかやばい、ガチっぽくなってきちゃった
これもツイストでロック
危ないから離れるんだ！ 爆発するぞ！
気を付けてね～(´∀｀ )ﾉｼ
ﾊﾞｲﾊﾞｲ (´∀｀*)ﾉｼ
はい、で ここからは たぶんこれ､
もう待って、もう飛ぶのかな?!
まじで怖い
もう飛ぶ気がしてきた！
次はロケットを実際にここに付けます
えー待って、どう付けるの…
こう、普通にこれでいいの？ これで…
うわぁ～ こ～わっ
で、えーっと、ONにします､
うわ、やばい ちょっと待って、本当にやばい
あ、やばい あっこれ、あっ大丈夫、電源ちゃんと付いてます、電気つきました
で、なんか３～４分後に「ラウンチトーン！」っていう音が聞こえてくるらしいです
はい、というわけで一応もう準備はできてるみたいでございます
今、水素作っててぇー
「ラウンチトーン」って音が聞こえて､
これをプッシュするともうファイヤーするらしいです
今、燃料が確実に…
作られていっておりますw
待って待って！ 何なに？
もう？ 待って待って待って！
え？
ラウンチトーンっていう音だったんだね…
もういけるはずです！
さっきなんかピーピーピーピー言ってたんで､
では、水素ロケット､
飛ばしてみようと思います｡
３！
２！
１！
なんなかったです…
なんで なんなかったんだろう？
あのーたぶんね、音が鳴ってた時にやんなきゃいけなかった説がありますね
( カメラ： あーそれある、わかる )
絶対そうだよね！
ピッピッピッピッてあの、なんか～
鳴ってる時に押せば、たぶん飛ぶみたいです
Reset switch to off when... then on after each launch...
オッケーオッケー問題ないっす
うん、たぶんこれでもう一回ピッピ鳴ったらいけます
きた？ きた？ きた？ きた？
来たなー！
離れろ！ 来るぞ… 来るぞ…
あっ、今だ…
ゴミ拾いだー
ゴミ拾おう、ゴミ